what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich for us
let's just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
planet evil over meredith we in miami
that's right we're in miami if you're in
miami let us know in the comments
that's where we are uh block five is now
the sponsor of lunch money you should go
get a blockbuy account that's right you
should just go get one buckeye.com
wifi.com you can buy and sell crypto on
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan
or you can use my favorite product as an
investor and a user which is that you
can deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent apy in an interest
bearing account go get a
block fi account wi-fi dot com slash
pomp what up
what's up guys not much what's going on
in the world
so first topic is america
um earlier today trump during a rally
encouraged thousands of supporters to
marcia the capitol to protest the
confirmation of biden's victory
uh trump despite telling the crowd he
would join them in the march of the
capital returns
to the white house and now the rioters
have actually stormed
the capital and uh the senate doors are
closed and locked and said
senators have been told to stay away
from the doors
i also read at one point they got told
to put on their gas masks
who the senators where do they have gas
masks underneath their seats
oh really because if they ever have to
gas people trying to storm it
which is what's happening i did not know
that was i don't want to comment on this
because we don't have all the
information yet
uh this is pretty crazy though so we'll
just leave it at that
um and we will tomorrow maybe talk about
it more
when we've got it just happened when
we're recording this so we don't really
we're recording at 259 so it's not
really lunch but it's more like you know
brunch money today
obviously it's not a good situation all
right next
what else you got for me let's talk
about oh you wanna talk about bitcoin
bitcoin at thirty five thousand six
hundred dollars wow
okay that's not what i wanted to talk
about go ahead but tesla
is now worth 725 billion dollars
moving closer to topping facebook
wow it's like tesla bitcoin tesla
bitcoin tesla bitcoin tesla oh so we
should just care about tesla not about
bitcoin
no they're they're chasing each other
but bitcoin will overtake it eventually
look this is a great example of young
people
understanding do you think electric
vehicles are going to be a thing go ask
a young person they'll say
duh you say what's the best electric
vehicle company they'll say
tesla wow that was hard if you say hey
do you think digital currencies are
going to be a thing
they're like duh like what do you think
the best digital currency like bitcoin
like wow that was hard
so guess what maybe young people
understand technology and innovation
better than not young people that's okay
there's so many things that could be
solved with young people
taking charge and control of things the
flip side is there's so many things that
we need experience and knowledge and
skills
from older people as well that's true
but i think the fresh ideas can come
from the younger generation speaking of
a fresh idea
mcdonald's is adding three new
sandwiches to compete
in the chicken wars chicken wars okay
uh new chicken sandwich will be
available nationally on february 24th
the crispy chicken sandwich topped with
pickles served on a potato roll i can't
say that potato
roll the spicy chicken sandwich and the
deluxe
chicken sandwich oh man there's spicy
chicken there's
fat chicken there's all kinds of chicken
i love mcdonald's but i've been eating
much healthier well
you like chicken and you like mcdonald's
i don't think that this counts as a
healthy chicken sandwich but the crisp
oh yeah because it's fried
i personally my favorite thing on the
menu is mcflurry
can you google something for me real
quick i think that it's national pancake
no just google it i'm pretty sure it is
today why i know this don't ask
no no it's not just kidding okay
somebody was tweeting at me tell me it
was national pancake day they were
probably trying to get you to say it on
lunch monday
it's not national pancake march 4th kids
march 4th i got you
we'll get pancakes on march 4th all
right are you ready yeah i like
mcflurries but the machines never work
thank you for your opinion and your
complaint
i will make sure to pass it along
there's now a red croc
how do i tell you i don't okay there's
now nearly a half
billion dollars nestled in the mega
millions jackpot
with no ticket matching all six numbers
drawn on tuesday
the game's top prize has ballooned to
490 million for friday night's drawing
powerball's jackpot isn't far behind
another 410 million
for the wednesday night drawing oh my
god
i mean that person taxes will take 200
away
so they'll be left with like 210 million
dollars
well i just find it very interesting
that the government is encouraging
gambling by allowing people to go and
buy lottery tickets and gambling tickets
but they don't allow them to invest in
private startups where true innovation
is happening to be fair
because of the people who gambled i got
to go to college for free
because uh the georgia lottery supported
kids going to college oh that's great
they they uh preyed on people who didn't
understand what they were doing it might
even have gambling addictions oh that
sounds
familiar that's not true i don't think
people with gambling addictions by
oh really i don't i don't i okay i don't
know i don't know
is that true i've seen people go in
you're thinking of the scratch-offs
oh they they buy scratch-offs they buy
power guys i bought a bunch of
scratch-offs for christmas
do you have a problem
okay i'm just i'm just saying that you
should allow people to invest if you're
gonna allow me to buy gambling tickets
today is a short one i'm very tired if
you can't tell
you see i had to get on a plane early
this morning
okay nicholas oh it's ask lunch money
time hashtag ask lynn
pretend to be excited i am excited okay
but you're not pretending
okay uh nicholas cuatroville asks
hi guys love what you do and thanks very
much for the education do you have any
recommendations for a documentary or
podcast to educate new people about
bitcoin and why it's so important
have a great day and all the best for
2021 well i know a certain someone who
does a podcast
no uh you should go to my youtube
channel and i literally did a video i
think that it's called
what is bitcoin and why is it important
go watch that one that one's a good one
do you have any documentaries or
um there's not really good documentaries
i don't think in terms of because it
changes so much that
well and also like why it's important as
much as like there's one like banking on
bitcoin but it's more about like the
early days and kind of documenting it
uh more so than um explaining why
bitcoin is important i have a
documentary
watch one called hank to it's not about
bitcoin
uh but it's about hank paulson during
the financial crisis and it
helps explain how we got to where we got
to yeah with the printing of money
by the way now that the democrats have a
fully consolidated government they're
gonna print trillions of dollars and
bitcoin's gonna move
okay all right well thank you very much
that's it see you next time all right
guys i really apologize for this being a
short episode but national pancake day
is march 4th and mcflurries are the best
see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends